how does that i want to ask you a
question yeah all politics aside how
does it feel to be the guy who like you
know i feel like hbk gang was you were
kind of like
the sixth man of the crew a bit
initially right shout out to sue great
guy but sue was kind of like the lebron
james i would say you were kind of like
caruso the underrated important piece
that nobody knew was the [ __ ]
until he went to the bulls and then the
lakers fell apart
how does it feel to be like
you're the most relevant popping
[ __ ] from that whole group and
like i feel like you weren't given the
flowers initially in that way
no no i don't even look at it like like
that i think i think it was just
that
that like situation or or the situation
that that i like came up through it was
just to build me
through and to like grow and learn a lot
of things there was a historical
movement out of the baby but i just
think it's dope to see you continuing to
level up yeah i mean i think it's just
it's just a testament to like everything
that i like everything that i learned
through that situation and from those
from those
important pieces in my life you know i'm
saying like sue and cool john and sage
and
all of them like you know i'm saying
they all played an important piece to to
what
i'm like continuing to build you know
what i'm saying like i learned a lot of
the a lot of things from those people
would you say like i
what would you say was your kind of
breakout moment
um
was it what i feel like the first
project like obviously there was the
project you had as a baby with i forget
the name of the product yeah more bits
more gold chains yeah but i really
[ __ ] love the movie albums yeah no
that was really that's really where it
was it was the move it was the movie
[ __ ]
i feel like that was kind of like an
idea like yeah like yeah like that kind
of like i mean like
because
what people really don't know like a lot
of those songs were movies were just
like some [ __ ] i was just like working
on you know what i'm saying like and
then like cool
then i mean coach i'm like oh let's just
do it let's just do a tape so i i had
like songs with like one verse on them
and then a hook
and then just like john will do hook and
then like
there were songs that you know that that
were on the giant project that ended up
just like being on a movie so we kind of
just like had like a bunch of songs that
we just put together
and um
and they became and then that became
movie and you know what i'm saying and
then from then i was able to pivot for a
movie
into you know what i'm saying like put
me on something
and all that stuff so it was like
it was it was what is that your biggest
record is the same squad
oh same same squad's got more streams
right yeah i think yeah i think sam's
crying like same squad's like an anthem
like all over the place put me on
something like that callie yeah yeah
yeah no for sure same squad like it's
like yeah
yeah like yeah like i think that's i
think that's obviously i think that's
the bigger song but like yeah man like
i'm excited for what was what's coming
in new [ __ ] coming new ship coming i'm
just trying to see if i can throw
another that's crazy bro how you just
literally bro
what else do i want to hear from this
guy i don't know tell me what else you
want to hear so
because yo man get some more beats from
this guy in a while yeah he he he needs
something you got you got some good
ideas man yeah there it is man you got
some good ideas
this guy has good ideas man